mais il y à dents chez vous dans leur
appartement un comportement bizarre oui
ça va bien ça va subir ce qui se passe
là vous voyez vous savez que je viens
très souvent c'est francis est bien
aussi souvent chez moi travaillons
ensemble alors quand je viens ici je
partage mon temps
ça c'est une détente j'ai très souvent
je reste des heures à la fenêtre
ah oui les yeux fixés sur la ligne bleue
de la place des vosges
oui il part et d'autre part je tricote
pour me détendre un peu du travail que
nous faisons
alors je m'entraîne en ce moment est ce
que vous faites comme j'aime ça c'est un
entraînement c'est ça c'est un petit
paillasson mais c'est un entraînement je
prétends affaires vont mieux
oui j'ai un truc là voyez vous dans un
magazine
l'élu d'un super difficile d'ailleurs
rio c'est le magazine ce magazine
prévient aussi le magazine de la femme
sur le retour et de la grand-mère
déchaînés c'est très bien et là il ya
une recette de tricot je vais arriver à
faire ça lespac com org
je voudrais vous donner cette recette
qu'ils espèrent faire d'ici quelques
jours quand je reviendrai dès que
j'aurai fini mon paillasson
c'est un passe montagne de plage à
manches retroussées ses propres mots
d'affaires d'ailleurs les fournitures il
faut pour faire ça il faut qu est ce qu
ils ont marqué à huy ces kilos 750 de
laine angora torse année 18 films 4 lot
de livres et demie de l'aide 24 fils
colorés aubergines tomates farcies et
une pelote basque de laine des pyrénées
coloris gitane vertu gauloises bleues
savaient déjà dissous ça les aiguille ça
s'est passé les mêmes que ça
l'aiguillerie voix sont des aiguilles
les aiguilles 1.31 des habous renforcer
alors les points il faut pour faire le
pass mon père dont on nous parle
y a comme point il ya les pentes jersey
point car 2ème point de suspension pour
les petits noeuds le point sur la hanche
pour l'empiècement et le point de pitié
pour les emmanchures à la voile à
l'exécution qui là c'est compliqué
voilà vous montez une 4 à 4 392 images
et vous ce côté 22 cm côté couture en
cordon et 14 centimètres cubes en
côtes-du-rhône
garnissez les enfants kodo qu'andris
vous rabattez dans le milieu l'iran de
chaque côté
à raison de 7 cm toutes les trois mois
vous travaillez simultanément la manche
et en terminant la fois en sens inverse
est extrêmement ont continué en sortant
deux mains et toutes les cinq minutes
et ceci pendant 12 m ben oui bah oui
faut ça quoi autant on arrivait à faire
leur propre
quand on a fini ce alors à mettre 75 du
bas afin du oui enfin du bon coin du
classico tôt parce que c'est de là les
valeurs pan am et 75 du prix du bois oui
rabat et 224 maille en diagonale et 6 x
78 mayans migiro versées alors là c'est
bon alors là vous n'avez plus qu'à
diminuer les moyens au fur et à mesure
mais comment les plus dingues c'est fini
mais alors qu'on annonce est à voir
c'est agréable parce que quand on arrive
à faire ça non seulement on a un très
jolie passe montagne de plage à manches
retroussées mais ça peut également
servir de serpillière et 2 et 2 et de
balayette de cuisine ou autre chose si
on veut enfin c'est bien je vais y
arriver
mariko voilà ce que je suis obligé de
tous les régimes
voilà